a ver vamos a hacer algunos ejemplos de
cómo se resuelven estos ejercicios dicen
aquí que nos dieron dos dados uno es
negro y tiene seis lados o sea es el
dado clásico y el otro es uno blanco
pero además tiene únicamente cuatro
lados
ok son estos dados triangulares y nos
dicen aquí que ya tiraron un dado pero
no nos dejaron ver qué es lo que le
salió en el dado y nos preguntan que
cuál es la probabilidad de que salga el
mismo número en ambos dados y por acá
nos dice que podemos seleccionar estas
casillas para contarlas más fácilmente
de hecho aquí nos dice cuántas casillas
tenemos seleccionadas y nos dicen que no
van a tomar en cuenta qué cosas
seleccionemos aquí que lo único que van
a tomar en cuenta es la respuesta que
escribamos por acá entonces queremos
calcular cuál es la probabilidad de que
salga el mismo número en ambos dados
entonces vamos a seleccionar aquí en
esta columna tenemos un 1 en todos los
datos negros y sólo tenemos un 1
en el dado blanco en esta casilla en
esta otra columna todos los dados negros
tienen un 2 y el único 2 del lado blanco
está en esta casilla por acá en esta
columna todos los dados negros tienen un
3 y el único 3 en los dados blancos es
este en esta columna hay puros cuatros
en el lado negro y esta es la única
casilla en la que el dado blanco también
es 4 aquí todos los dados negros son 5
pero en ningún dado blanco hay un 5 así
es que no tenemos que seleccionar
ninguna casilla de esta columna y en
esta columna pasa lo mismo o sea en los
dados negros salen puros 6x pero en el
lado blanco no puede salir ningún 6
porque sólo tiene cuatro lados entonces
estas cuatro casillas son las únicas
casillas en las que los dos dados son
iguales
uno dos tres cuatro de esas casillas
aquí nos dicen que hay cuatro casillas
seleccionadas y en total hay 1 2 3 4 4 x
1 2 3 4 5 6 6 x 4 24 entonces tenemos 4
casos favorables que son los casos en
los que sale el mismo número en ambos
dados 4 pero para calcular la
probabilidad tenemos que dividir los
casos favorables entre el número total
de casos que ya vimos que hay 24 casos
24 casos entonces vamos a checar y me
dice que mi respuesta es casi correcta
pero que necesito simplificar la y si
esta es una fracción que se puede
simplificar mucho no o sea 24 es igual a
6 por 4 y tenemos un 4 en el numerador
entonces esto es igual
entre 6 cierto porque 4 por 1 es 4 y 4
por 6 es 24 entonces podemos dejar esta
respuesta como un sexto y muy bien
tenemos una respuesta correcta ya nos
apareció la palomita por aquí y todo
entonces tenemos que ir al siguiente
ejercicio
otra vez nos dieron dos dados uno negro
con seis caras y uno blanco con cuatro
caras y ahora tenemos que ver cuál es la
probabilidad de que los dados sumen
siete o menos entonces sabemos que
podemos elegir las casillas para
contarlas más fácilmente pero vamos a
empezar de cero a ver uno más uno suma
siete no dos más uno suma siete para
nada pero nos están preguntando cuál es
la probabilidad de que los dados sumen
siete o menos entonces a ver uno más uno
es dos y dos es menor que siete entonces
si la tenemos que seleccionar dos más
uno es tres que también es menor que
siete
y este de aquí también es dos más uno
por aquí tres más uno es cuatro dos más
dos es cuatro tres más uno es cuatro y
en esta diagonal 41 es 53 más 12 52 13
51 45 seguimos sumando a lo largo de
diagonales que son menores o iguales a 7
a ver vamos a sumar esta diagonal 5 096
que es menor que 74 12 633 de 6 412 6 y
por aquí tenemos que seis más uno es 7
así es que si tenemos que contar este
caso 5 + 12 74 13 7 y 3 más 4 también es
7 a ver por aquí 6 + 2 es 8 y ese número
si ya es más grande que 7 entonces no lo
tenemos que seleccionar y aquí tenemos
53 también es 84 48 no debemos
seleccionar ninguna de estas casillas 45
es 9
63 también es 9 y finalmente 64 es 10 y
tampoco lo queremos seleccionar entonces
aquí nos dice que seleccionamos 18
castilla podríamos contar las 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 7 18 y en
total hay 24 casillas entonces tenemos
que la probabilidad de que los dados
sumen 7 o menos es casos favorables o
sea casillas en las que los dados sumen
7 o menos que ya vimos que son 18 10 y 8
entre casos totales que es el número
total de casillas que son 24 24 pero
para que no nos pase lo mismo que la vez
pasada de una vez por todas vamos a
simplificar esta fracción a ver 18 es
igual a 3
3 por 2 y estamos dividiendo entre 24
que es igual a 6 por 4 y este 6 es un 3
por 2
entonces vamos a cancelar este 3 por 2
con este 6 y nos quedan tres cuartos así
es que vamos a comprobar nuestra
respuesta muy bien ya nos pusieron
palomita otra vez entonces vamos con la
siguiente pregunta a ver tenemos la
misma situación de dados negros y dados
blancos y nos preguntan qué cuál es la
probabilidad de que al menos un dado sea
uno entonces vamos a buscar en todas
estas casillas en cuáles hay por lo
menos 11 a ver aquí hay dos dados
entonces sí por lo menos hay un 1 en
todas estas el dado es igual a 1
entonces lo seleccionamos y en toda esta
fila el dado blanco es igual a 1
entonces también las tenemos que
seleccionar y por aquí pues por aquí
todos estos dados son mayores a 1 cierto
entonces no los debemos de seleccionar
así es que tenemos uno dos tres cuatro
cinco seis siete ocho nueve casillas en
las que al menos un dado es igual a uno
entonces tenemos nueve casos favorables
que tenemos que dividir entre los casos
totales o sea el número de casillas que
es 1234 por 1 2 3 4 5 6 6 por 4 24 son
en total 24 posibles resultados al tirar
dos dados
uno de seis lados y otro de cuatro lados
son nuestras 24 casillas por acá y otra
vez tenemos que simplificar nuestra
respuesta y nos queda 3 entre 8 entonces
la probabilidad de que al menos un dado
sea igual a 1 es 3 octavos a ver vamos a
ver si es cierto muy bien estamos
haciendo muy bien estos ejercicios así
es que te va a tocar hacer muchos más